[Música]
porque tras la llegada de los talibanes
al poder en afganistán la situación de
las mujeres en ese país ha empeorado ya
que los avances civiles y políticos se
han minimizado por la gobernanza bajo la
ley islámica la 'sharia' por ahora y a
pesar de las promesas de los talibanes
de permitir que las mujeres reciban
educación todavía no se sabe cuándo se
les permitirá volver a sus estudios
universitarios y también escolares es
que los talibanes se prometieron mostrar
más moderación que durante su gobierno
de 1996 a 2001 cuando se prohíbe a las
niñas asistir a las escuelas y a las
mujeres a trabajar fuera de sus hogares
las mujeres afganas acusan al nuevo
gobierno dirigido exclusivamente por
hombres de romper sus promesas muchas
dicen que el regreso del régimen talibán
se siente como si fueran sentenciadas a
cadena perpetua app perpetua e incluso
aseguran que han tenido pensamientos
suicidas y de depresión para ello quiero
saludar en este momento a susana
manganas directora de la cátedra de
islam de la universidad católica de
uruguay y analista política interna
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 para
analizar esta difícil y delicada
situación de las mujeres en afganistán
le pregunto cómo lo usted cuál es el
panorama de ellas gracias a vosotros
raúl y efectivamente es una situación
muy trágica la que vive en todas las
mujeres también por cierto niños jóvenes
hombres todos aquellos que han quedado
atrás viviendo la violencia cotidiana
bajo el régimen talibán pero recordemos
que las mujeres han sido siempre las
personas más castigadas de la sociedad
afgana que se ve atravesada por sus
tratos culturales y todavía muy
conservadores patriarcales y que por
tanto permanece esa costumbre de los
matrimonios forzosos con lo cual a esa
situación se le suma ahora la pobreza
hay una recesión económica realmente
peliaguda podríamos decir a menos que se
liberen fondos a nivel internacional de
manera urgente para el gobierno de los
talibán y por tanto las mujeres se ven
de alguna manera secuestradas siquier o
encerradas en sus domicilios sin
posibilidad de salir sin la presencia de
un guardián de un
bajar a un compañero una compañía
masculina que evidentemente tiene que
ser un padre un hermano un tío o el
propio esposo por lo cual muchas de
ellas también en el exterior las
refugiadas para las que hemos podido
hablar raúl nos confiesan que eso es una
muerte en vida
susana le quiero preguntar por qué las
mujeres son tan afectadas bajo esta
gobernanza de la ley islámica también
conocida como la sharía
bien porque evidentemente vivir y vivir
bajo un régimen islamista o vivir con
las leyes de la sharía significa aplicar
un estricto código de moral y de
obediencia a las mujeres tienen que
mostrarse recatadas modestas no pueden
estar en el espacio público sin esa
compañía de un majar and un guardian que
vele para que las mujeres se comporten
con rectitud pero para que también nos
sean molestadas y si bien el islam
permite fomentar la educación de las
mujeres incluso como dije antes en
afganistán todavía rigen códigos
tribales y tenemos que saber que no es
un país homogéneo no hay una unidad
nacional como la que sospechamos
presuponemos desde occidente sino que es
una sumatoria de tribus donde además hoy
por hoy rigen la vida de las personas lo
que llamamos señores de la guerra
étnicos con lo cual el clima es muy
hostil hacia las personas más pobres
solamente aquellos que tiene una
posición más acomodada pueden haber
enviado a sus hijas al exterior o por
ejemplo están en irán o en pakistán pero
aquellos que quedaron atrás que es lo
que nos comentan las personas refugiadas
con las que hablamos casi de manera
cotidiana están viviendo bajo muchísimo
estrés con lo cual no sólo las mujeres
pensamientos suicidas también algunos
hombres usted ya lo comentaba estas
conversaciones con estas personas
afectadas por el régimen talibán que más
que es lo que más los agobia mentalmente
susana pues les agobia te voy a decir
raúl muy claramente no quieren que la
comunidad internacional vale decir los
países más avanzados y desarrollados
validen o acepten y reconozcan al
gobierno de los talibán lo que piden una
y otra vez es que no se lo reconozca
para que no puedan gobernar para que no
sean el gobernante legítimo de su país y
lamentablemente muchas tenemos que
torcer la cara y voltear la vista raúl
porque sabemos que eso ya ha ocurrido de
facto desde que el año pasado en febrero
del 2020 en la administración de donald
trump negoció con los talibán la
retirada la salida de las tropas
estadounidenses y ahora con la
negociación de países importantes en la
región como pueden ser turquía irán pero
la propia rusia o china con el gobierno
de los talibán está todo dicho con lo
cual sentimos mucha pena mucha tristeza
porque lo que nos piden no es una utopía
no va a ocurrir por ahora el gobierno
que está en pie en kabul es el de los
talibán con lo cual eso es lo que las
estrés en las agobia porque ellas
también lo saben y cuál podría ser
entonces se sana una solución si no se
negocia con con el grupo talibán que son
los que están realmente mandando en en
kabul digamos el gobierno el gobierno
central entonces qué va a pasar con
quién se negocia para poder mejorar esta
situación tan trágica que vienen las
mujeres y los niños también y ya incluso
a hombres como usted decía
efectivamente ahora dos bueno eso es lo
que les hacemos entender que incluso
para hacer llegar la cooperación para
poder hacer salir más aviones fletar más
aviones españa o desde otros países que
quieran seguir sacando órganos del país
porque las listas de espera son enormes
pues evidentemente se tiene que tener
una negociación con aquellos que rigen y
que están gobernando en el país que son
los talibán ahora bien lo que sí se
puede hacer desde las cancillerías
europeas desde canadá o eeuu es
presionar a este régimen de los talibán
porque también tienen pies de barro es
decir tiene una debilidad económica
importante hay muchísimas personas que
están viviendo inseguridad alimentaria
muchísimos que precisan ayuda del
gobierno de los talibán e incluso otros
tantos que están sin recibir su sueldo
desde hace meses con lo cual a los
talibán hay espacio para presionarles lo
que pasa que hay que contar también con
la ayuda de aquellos países que por
ahora están viendo los pingos beneficios
que pueden obtener negociando con los
talibán que son los mismos que comenté
antes china o rusia por ejemplo iraní y
el propio pakistán que es el que ha
salido ganando con la salida de las
tropas de la otan y de eeuu y con el
regreso de los talibán raúl y mientras
tanto las mujeres seguirán entonces
estando condenada a susana una última
reflexión 30
pues lo importante es no olvidar las
agradezco este espacio lo que estás
haciendo con el programa porque
evidentemente tenemos que seguir
hablando de las mujeres y del pueblo
afgano y no sólo correr y espantarnos
cuando vemos imágenes
lacerantes como las de aquellos que
querían subirse al fuselaje del avión
cuando llegaron los talibán a kabul